hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com
so first guys sorry i wasn't there with
you
yesterday on my discord when amc was
actually going lower
it was my first night out so you know i
went to see my friends i went to the
restaurant
just had some you know good time to get
back some energy
and make an analysis today with you guys
on amc
so let's get into it
all right so as usual let's start i was
here in a five minute time frame i'm
gonna show you
everything that happened yesterday i'm
gonna give you
as usual remind you what was my first
scenario
that i'm posting every day guys on my
discord so here
once again i'll just remind you quickly
the situation we have here
this huge breakout all right that is
very clear
that has retested so this breakout comes
from this trend line guys
it has been rejected here then we went
through it so this is confirming that
this breakout
is followed by many investors then it's
been retested we had the reaction then
we
just had this access here that for me
is you know happening sometimes we had
it before as well
so it's nothing too bad for me and then
here we strongly bounce back on monday
you know so this was very expected very
much expected and here we
still have this bullish momentum that is
coming from this
medium term breakout that is going to
impact the price action for the coming
week two weeks even maybe three weeks so
not so sure how long this would take but
the breakout is here
everybody so it's gonna impact the price
action so
here this is the reason why so let's
zoom in a little bit i was expecting to
have the fifth
wave alright i was expecting something
like this yesterday i was bullish
and let me explain why i was bullish so
the first reason
is that indeed i have a bullish bias in
this situation
not because i just want amc to go higher
is because i have this breakout
all right guys if it was a breakout on
the downside i would have a bearish bias
so here i have a bullish bias indeed
it's not only that guys here you can see
that we had one two three so in this
recovery
on that happened on monday one two three
very clear
four for me that has been broken on the
upside
you can see here we have the breakout we
went higher on the open
yesterday we opened at 40.6 and here you
can see that we
failed actually to go higher so this is
definitely not good
i didn't expect that we can try to see
it was interesting to see if we had some
early signals that could have you know
tell us that
the reversal here the pullback it's only
a pullback right it's a short-term
pullback so it's nothing too bad
i'm gonna explain here what it means for
me let's see if we could
have guessed we have this once again i
like to use the five minutes divergences
with the macd
on amc and you can see that here we had
the
very first little signal you can see
that here the magnet is going slightly
lower guys
from here to here but it's so small you
know it's very hard to use
those when they are not clear enough and
this one is here
it's real it's a divergence the magnet
is going lower lower highs
when the price action is making higher
highs but it's you know so
small that you know it's hard to
actually use
and trust but anyway we had it and then
here we didn't make a high
high all right so we failed so here we
don't have a divergence so the only
thing that we could have used
in this situation is the moving averages
you can see that the 50 percent moving
average
was supporting the price very well the
whole way up only here we had this you
know on the 15 minutes time frame we
didn't have a breakout
okay you can see the 20 period moving
average under 15 minutes time frame
has never been broken twice only here
guys alright
so this could have been the information
that you could use to know that you're
gonna have a short term reversal but it
was pretty tough let's be honest
so now let's see what this means for the
next price action let's see what this
means for the next moves so here
my labeling is gonna stay like this i
could still do something like this
you're gonna
you know uh one two three we could still
make a counting like this but you know
it's it's a valid counting the third
wave is not the shortest but the third
wave
doesn't contain five waves i don't know
to me it's more like this
and this is a truncated fifth that's all
it can be for me then here we have a
zigzag all right so let's see
how deep we trace because it's important
the deeper we go
the worse it is of course we don't like
to have those retracements those
pullbacks too deep
and here what's the level guys let's see
all right so here we went to the 61.8
37.05 right so 61.8 percent so
as you guys know it's a typical
retracement level for a zigzag
especially in a second wave let's say
that this
all looks good to me for now once again
we are in the third wave
so if this counting is correct
we need to have some strong moves up
guys all right
we are in the third it might be the
third of the third right it might be
like this
but if this is to be correct we need
some strong moves up right now
for now i see a little bit of weakness
here so i'm still bullish of course
but we need to have something strong
coming very quickly otherwise
this bullish momentum coming from this
breakout is gonna start to fade
people are gonna start to doubt to
forget that we are bullish
and you know bears could take back
control so
bulls need to win the battle
today and this week so that this
breakout is
definitely confirmed all right guys so
that's the game stop quickly
on amc that's all i can tell you guys so
we expect some moves up you know we
expect this price action to come back
and on game stop
nothing much to say yes you know 180
is still the major pivot point for me
you can see the price action is hovering
around this level i'm not sure what is
this it might be a leading diagonal so
if we go to 200 it would confirm that we
have
you know five waves up that even if it's
messy a bit
it's still in five waves so it's good we
like to see five waves going
higher which means the the trend is
actually up
so let's see for now not much
information here the price section is
just pretty steady volumes are
still low so let's find out what is
happening here
and that's it for me guys i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys